how are you feeling watching it two
episodes in you drown yourself I'm
pretty proud of myself and me sometimes
I'm like SMA shake my head but most the
time I'm like ah like I recognized that
girl like that is Hana you can cut that
picture of tension with a knife
this season's coming in hot things are
happening the top thing that you've said
you wanted out of the guys was for them
to be real and last night on Monday
night's episode
Luke P said he was starting to fall in
love with you that we said it was
trending online that fans were not
believing Luke P watching it back what
did you think did you believe him I sure
not even talked about like watching it
back as much as like in the moment he
was the person that I had the first
connection like real indescribable
connection with I would say and so if
anybody was gonna say it I would more so
believe Luke out of anybody but even
when he started talking I was like my
god he's saying it oh my god are you
really saying that yep
you said it so I mean part of me was
giddy and like oh this guy that I'm like
starting to like more than likes me but
likes me at least and so like there's
excitement in that but then you know at
the end of the night I started
questioning in a little bit too but yeah
I'm yeah there's part of me that
question it a little bit but then also
you know I'm there for people to start
developing feelings for me in this quick
pace and so there was part of me that
was a little helpful it was real quick
those real quick what in the moment was
it awkward for you absolutely it was
very awkward with all the other guys
there too and Mike an audience and like
yeah it was awkward and all I meant but
then also like
I mean honestly a part of me was kind of
like Oh like I'm glad this guy likes me
but that's more than like and now
everybody knows how you I how you feel
should the fans believe Luke because we
see in that season trailer they call him
a liar a psychopath manipulative yeah
what should fans be wary about or
watching for with Luke you know there is
a lot of a lot of my season revolves
around my relationship with Luke and
Luke relationship with the other men and
so I think it is something that the
audience will really have to tune in and
see how that relationship evolves with
with me and Luke relationship with the
guys we saw it evolve real quick - a
little shirtless moment last night oh
yeah I mean a Hannah look to me I felt
I'm watching two people with an insane
physical attraction to each other how
would you describe it does that
accelerate you and Luke because you're
so attracted to him I would say like
even just like kissing him there's just
there's just like this like chemistry
that is undeniable and yeah there is a
definitely a physical attraction there
the physical attraction there that
accelerated it way faster and off the
charts compared to a lot of my other
relationships and that massage was did
your dad give you a call my mom did she
said look I love that you're saying he's
a desert I love that you're saying what
you're into but we also see this moment
in the trailer where Luke is screaming
at another guy hmm what was it like for
you to see that footage I don't know if
you've seen it before that I haven't
seen that before um so yeah it's it's
going to be interesting for me to watch
some of the things that happen because
you know I only
I only know what happens in the
interactions that I have with the men
and what they say to me and what I feel
with them I don't know what happens
anywhere else so just see some of the
things in the teasers I'm like huh
interesting do you think you'll learn
stuff about Luke you maybe didn't know
before I think that's possible I didn't
know the stream of that what was your
reaction when you saw that man it's a
little scary I'll be honest it's scary
to me it's screaming at somebody else
yeah intense you said on Monday night's
episode I'm the type of person who
zeroes in on somebody and part of me
wants to do that with Luke P did you
have to stop yourself from zeroing in on
him yeah I mean especially I mean I'm
not gonna pretend like it's not obvious
last episode I mean I'm like like I am
and so I really was struggling last
episode with okay like it's not just
sleepy but I think even him might be
like I'm starting to fall in love with
you was like yeah but also like all
right that's a lot one time let me not
go all in like that right now because if
I do that what am I gonna do the rest of
the time so I really did have to kind of
pump the brakes for myself with him
because yeah I am when that would just
zero in on somebody and if we're looking
right now pee-yew it's really easy for
me that's you're in well things are
speeding up he's saying I'm starting to
fall in love with you the shirts coming
off you guys are on like Episode seven
we definitely have like our emotional
and physical connection is like far
beyond the other man so what are the
other guys do to catch up or do they
catch up to see are you one of those
bachelorettes are you gonna be number
five to wind up with the first rose the
first impression rose guy I don't know I
didn't like think about that wasn't I
mean of course like I knew that was a
thing
but when I gave out my first impression
rose I wasn't like oh well
it's Luke P now so let me just like that
wasn't the reason that I
I sure P its bus like no gonna mess it
up I'm here for Hannah and don't you
ever forget it
had you seen that intense side of Luke
before no not with me what or who makes
Hannah beasts to come out the most from
what we've seen I definitely think good
that would be Scott from the first
episode but I will say if these guys do
anything to bother me the Beast will
continue to come out
Chris Harrison said that there might be
more man drama this season than any
other season before I would agree I mean
but I think the reason there is so much
man drama is because the guys are
invested and care and when you're
passionate about something or someone
and how you feel then you have emotional
reactions and responses to things in the
promo we hear you telling someone that
they don't own you and your words are
really powerful there what made you
react like that what is that
conversation well I can't exactly tell
me whatever you can read the
conversation but I will say that for me
to be that emotional about something
it's when somebody like judges my
character and when I stay in for and
tries to take own you know ownership and
have claim over me and I met in person
about an individual and I have worked
really hard to break chains of any type
of recognition validation stereotype
anything to define who I believe that I
am or who anybody else defines me as and
so that is one thing that'll really
upset me if anybody tries to define me
is something that I'm not or make me to
be something that in their mind they
believe that I'm I am that I'm just not
and so that is one thing that I think is
really hard being the Bachelorette and
something that
you go into thinking you know if they
just want to take me because they think
I'm the Bachelorette or just from what
they seen on social media but they just
had this hype in their head of what they
think that I am and it's really about
know at the time that you spend would
mean this is who I am and me really
that's why I'm so passionate about like
be yourself be real like I'm gonna be
completely really this is me you say
I've had sex and Jesus still loves me
was that in reference to fantasy suites
or just in general well I think without
like giving anything away I think a lot
of times like my faith is I'm so glad
that even in the first episode they
talked they even showed like my prayer
which I had no idea like that was just
me really truly like praying before
meeting the guys but that is a big huge
part of me and so I'm really blessed
that even that small clip was shown and
a lot of times people get Christianity
and religion messed up because your
faith should be something personal in a
relationship and it's not to judge
others or say Christianity is something
that you welcome others into and should
be a place where people feel safe and
welcomed not it seems like you felt
judged or shamed yes and not to feel
judged or shamed and it's like
regardless of any thing that I've done
it that people might think oh well that
deserves a scarlet letter that's not how
it works like I can do whatever I send
daily and Jesus still loves me like it's
all washed and do not and if the Lord
doesn't judge me and it's all forgiven
then no other man woman animal anything
I don't know anything
nobody's judging Hanabi nobody's gonna
judge me I won't say more I'm gonna
speak my mind about it was it about sex
in the fantasy suites you'll have to see
okay what can you tease about fantasy
suites drama
I think it's I'll say my fantasy suite
is different than any fantasy suite week
ever before I think it has more weight
okay more emotional weight it sounds
like okay like a bigger picture okay
well I don't like you being shamed I was
glad you stood up for yourself yeah I
think because I've shamed myself so much
I felt guilty for things I mean even my
first conversation with kolten I talked
about my it can be an aversion and me
not and how it really affected me
because I always thought that I would
save myself for marriage and I happened
in hell for a long time I carried shame
and guilt around and then I realized
that like I shouldn't and he was so
receptive of that and just just stand up
in that conversation and really that was
something I struggle with and now that
like honestly my faith has grown so much
and I realized like what relationship
with the Lord is really about I don't
have to carry that and for have somebody
to have to ever have anybody make me
feel that way it's a little messed up
and I'm not gonna stand for that because
if I feel like that way I know there's
other people out in the world that feel
that way and maybe if I can stand up for
myself other people can feel like they
well yeah it's crazy to me in 2019 you
know but like Kaitlyn Bristowe talked
about how in her season she felt a
little shamed for like talking about her
sexuality and as a guest be a woman talk
about being attracted someone you can do
all that and I love that you did episode
2 you're like he's a dessert yeah man
and what's so funny is like I feel like
I'm one of the the least expected to do
it because I am like this southern
pristine I'd only kissed five guys but
like it's every woman thinks about it
talks about it we all talk about it with
our girlfriends and I'm just living my
life and being real and speaking what
I'm actually thinking yeah look he was
like a desert who do you have the
strongest desert connection to who do
you have the strongest chemistry with
well
not everything says like there's people
who are like deserts and then there's
you know you have your desert but then
like you can't be a desert for every
single meal okay some people are like
healthy salads like the good salad like
the avocado the grilled chicken somebody
maybe a steak sonic vinaigrette that
somebody might need the steak and potato
somebody might be a nice pasta like what
are you but like you can't eat steak no
you can't eat a salad so it sounds like
you experience a variety of cuisines yes
we just interviewed Chris Harrison who
he said that you guys had a great
relationship it was kind of
father/daughter it was really solid he
told us he wasn't sure if this season
would end in a proposal why would he say
that
because it was such a missional and look
I will be the first to say that I was a
pain in the butt to deal with because it
worked for Christie like he's like Oh
God
how are you today what are we working
with yep today which how are you feeling
today Anna um do I need to sit down yeah
okay so I was just really emotional I
think it was because of the
relationships I had with the guys and
how those affected me and what was going
on between the men in the house and so
was there a question of if I remember
talking to you at your photo shooting
you're like I won't necessarily get
engaged at the end of all and I even
said that even when discussing if I
wanted to do this if I don't feel like I
could give everything to a person and
that it was really true like I I won't
and it's really hard to feel that way
when you have to compartmentalize
relationships you get set back when
things go wrong and I had a lot of
breakdowns and okay it was yeah it was a
really hard time
human being I try to be I don't know
what to do you told us I think just a
couple days ago you said things didn't
necessarily end the way you thought that
they would know they didn't how so what
do you mean by that I just I guess I
knew it was gonna be like hard but not
as hard as it was and just like
emotionally physically like you think
you're gonna hit one part where it's
like okay like that was that that was
the hardest thing and then it's like
again like like when is it gonna get
easier when is your biggest breakdown I
don't know if I can answer that because
there I have a few very pivotal
breakdowns for different reasons but
like even up until like the last I have
like sounds like there's one towards the
end yeah but like I mean yeah they're
significant breakdowns when or what is
your fence jump like I've said it a lot
like I people say like Oh what do you
have a fence shut my mouth like honestly
I feel like they're multiple like every
episode there's a fence gentlemen well
with all the breakdowns did you doubt at
any point did you wonder am I gonna get
a happy ending out of all this oh
absolutely
I would say most of the time most of the
time you wondered if it would all go so
it was truly the hardest thing and it
sound like I didn't want to let like
other people down but it's like I didn't
want to let myself down like did I just
have I been going through all this for
nothing but yes something because I'm
growing and learning but yeah it's it's
an interesting thing are you engaged I
would say I'm really like I'm really
happy for the opportunity I had and I'm
excited for everybody to see the growth
and what I learned and how Mike's
Thank You president Hanna what a good
politically correct answer
[Music]